there are almost 300,000 alumni that are
part of this Columbia lon my association
from all 16 schools of the University we
all share a bond because we went to
Columbia there is a common experience
that's in the past but the CAA draws on
that draws on whatever affinity or
affiliation feel based on that to build
an experience in the present as
president Bollinger was saying we are
leaders Columbia is a leader in the
world I feel very privileged to be a
part of this wonderful alumni body part
of my mission or what I would like to
see is every alumni in some way shape or
form whether it's small or large be
connected every single year with
Columbia University go to an event
contact your roommate send in a story
forward a magazine article do one
Columbia thing you haven't done before
as an alumnus or an alumna and find out
what the alumni experience can mean to
you CAA is energy CAA is adventure gray
is family the AAA is friend the CAA is
timeless the CIA is tailor-made the CAA
is celebration
the CAA is diversity the CA is the
Columbia spirit CAA is where you want to
be
you